استعرض شباب سعوديون في معرض اكسبو للحج
الذي استضافته جده قبل ايام استعرضوا
خدمات برنامج ضيوف الرحمن والتي تبدا من
وصول الحاج او المعتمر وحتى مغادرته مرورا
بكامل محطات زيارته متابع
[موسيقى]
الاهداف من مقدم الخدمات وممثلي الحجاج من
57 دوله وفرصه لشباب وشبات السعوديه
لتقديم تجارب واقعيه للزوار من خلال رحله
تبدا من الوصول لها التنقل ثم زياره
الحرمين والمشاعر المقدسه مرورا بتجارب
الثقافيه ترسخ في ذاكره الحجاج والمرتبرين
حياكم الله في جناح برنامج كل الضيوف
الرحمن في مؤتمر ومعرض خدمات الحج والعمره
اكسبوا الحج 20 23 لاخذكم في جوله لرحله
ضيف الرحمن
هاخذكم ان شاء الله اليوم على المرحله
الاولى الانطباع الاول الانطباع الاول
تتكون من ثلاثه نقاط اتصال ما قبل الوصول
وتشمل كل ما يكون ضد ضيف الرحمن قبل
الوصول كتاشيرات وعندنا قدوم المغادره
ويشمل المنافذ البحريه والجويه والبريه
والتنقل بين المدن
[موسيقى]
المرحله الثانيه هي مرحله اداء المسك اللي
بتساعد في رفع جوده الخدمات اللي موجوده
في المسجد الحرام والمسجد النبوي المشاعر
المقدسه والمواقيت
هنتكلم اليوم على المرحله الثالثه وهي
مرحله اثراء التجربه وفيها مزارع المسار
الضيافه ومسار اكتشاف المملكه وبشاف
المملكه يهتم بالمواقع التاريخيه
والواجبات الاسرائيليه
بناء على الدراسات اللي سمعته عنها تم
تصميم العديد من المبادرات الحكوميه وايضا
الاستثماريه وغير الربحيه والقطاع غير
ربحي كمان منظومه يركز عليه البرنامج
ويعطيها اولويه كبيره في تمكينه من خلال
مبادرات عديده
الشعار البرنامج ومنهجيه دائما التفكير في
رحله ضيف الرحمن من الفكره الى الذكر
[موسيقى]
هاعرفكم على اخر نقطه في جناح البرنامج
وهي القاع الاثرائيه واللي تعرض اركانها
تجربه ضيوف الرحمن في الوقت الحالي ضمن
رؤيه المملكه 20/03
لضيوف الرحمن من خلال تسهيل الاجراءات
وتسيرها لاستضافه المزيد من المعتمرين
وتهيئه مواقع التاريخ الاسلامي لافراء
تجربه الدينيه والثقافيه للحجاج
والمعتمرين وتحقيق التكامل في الخدمات
لتمكين 30 مليون معتمر من تجربه ايمانيه
من الفكره للذكرى محمد الزهراني العربيه
جدا